THIS A HEARING TO ORDER BUT
WE'RE GONNA SYMBOL UP AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE FIRST IT UNTIL WE
CAN GATHER QUORUM.
SO WE ARE.
HERE BY.
OPENING COMMITTEE HEARING --
WHEN I'M GOING TO ANNOUNCEMENTS
MEASURES ON FILE FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWO A. B. TWO TEN VOEPEL
HAS BEEN PULLED BY THE AUTHOR?
MEASURES ON CONSENT FILE ITEM
SIX AB FOUR OH EIGHT FRAZIER.
FILE ITEM NUMBER SEVEN AB FOR
TWO TO FRAZIER.
FILE ITEM NUMBER EIGHT AB FOUR
FOUR NINE NOT FRAZIER GALLAGHER.
AB FOR OUR SUSIE FILE ITEM
NUMBER -- NINE AB SIX FIVE NINE
MULLIN.
FILE ITEM NUMBER TEN A. B. SIX
SEVEN SIX FRAZIER.
FILE ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN A. B.
NINE EIGHTY KALRA.
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWELVE AC OR
THIRTY SEVEN EDUARDO GARCIA
ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
SO WE CAN HAVE ANY MOTIONS
MOVING FORCE WILL GO AHEAD AND
PARTICIPATE IN THE SUBCOMMITTEE
WILL COLOR FIRST AUTHOR -- AB
TWENTY NINE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
HOLDEN PLEASE COME UP TO THE
GOOD AFTERNOON SIR PLEASE
PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT -- A. B. TWENTY NINE A
SOLUTION TO A PROBLEM THAT HAS
BEEN DIVIDING THE SAN GABRIEL
VALLEY FOR FAR TOO LONG.
THE BILL REMOVES THE MOST
DISPUTED LAND YOU KNOW THE SR
SEVEN AND FROM THE FREEWAY AND
EXPRESSWAY CODE ALIGNING THE LAW.
WITH THE DESIRES OF THE CITIES
AND THE FINALIZE CALTRAIN AND
YEAH I ARE. FOR TOO LONG OF THE
STATE HAS BEEN TRYING TO DICTATE
WHEN THE LOCAL COMMUNITY CAN DO
WHAT IT CAN DO WITH ITS AREA
WITHIN THIS AREA.
AS SORT OF A COLLABORATIVE
SOLUTION CALTRANS CREATED AN
EITHER OR SITUATION THAT
REQUIRED THE COMMUNITIES TO TAKE
SIDES ALMOST SIXTY YEARS AGO BY
PROPOSING A FREEWAY.
THAT KEPT THIS LAND STAGNANT FOR
YEARS AND WHILE THE REST OF THE
COMMUNITY GREW AND DEVELOPED
AROUND IT.
LAST YEAR LA METRO CALTRANS A
CLEAR THE LOOK LOCALLY PREFERRED
ALTERNATIVE TO BE TRAFFIC DEMAND
MANAGEMENT NOT A FREEWAY.
THIS IS REFLECTED IN THE
FINALIZED BY OUR NOW ALL OF THE
COMMUNITIES THAT USED TO BE AT
ODDS.
ARE AT THE TABLE TOGETHER
DISCUSSING HOW TO MOVE FORWARD
TOGETHER.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT WAS
UNFATHOMABLE JUST ONE YEAR AGO.
I PLAN TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
THE IMPACT OF CITIES IN CALTRANS
TO TAKE THE NEXT STEPS WHICH
INCLUDES RELINQUISHING THE LAND
INTO THEIR JURISDICTION TO ALLOW
THEM TO DECIDE HOW.
THIS DISPUTED LAND SERVE THE
WHOLE COMMUNITY.
THIS BILL WILL ALLOW THEM TO
BUILD AFFORDABLE HOUSING CREATE
GREEN SPACE GREAT BIKE LANES AND
DEDICATED BUS ROUTES INSTEAD OF
CROWDED STREETS.
BUILD MAKES YOU SPACE SPACES FOR
RETAIL HOUSING ENTERTAINMENT AND
WHATEVER ELSE THESE COMMUNITIES
CAN DREAM UP.
WE'RE AT A TIPPING POINT WITH
WITH THE SIXTY YEAR PROJECT AND
ASK THE COMMITTEE TO HELP US GET
OVER THE FINISH LINE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK A REQUEST
YOUR AYE VOTE ON THIS BILL AND
LET ME ALSO STATE -- THIS BILL
HAS NO OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU MISTER WILL YOU HAVE
ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL I DO.
NAMELY REPRESENT PLEASE.
GET UP NUCLEAR ROSS ON BEHALF OF
THE CITY OF PASADENA.
REMOVING THE ROADWAY FROM THE
STATE HIGHWAY INVENTORIES BUT
THE TOP PRIORITY FOR THE CITY
AND AN IMPORTANT FIRST STEP IN
KNITTING THE LOCAL COMMUNITY.
BACK TOGETHER WITH MANY CRITICAL
LOCAL INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS
INCLUDING NEW AFFORDABLE HOUSING
WE ARE THANKFUL FOR THE AUTHORS
EFFORTS ON THIS ISSUE AND READY
TO WORK WITH ALL THE LOCAL AND
STATE PARTNERS ON THIS PROJECT
TO CONTINUE THE PROCESS OF
RELINQUISHMENT.
AB TWENTY NINE MOVE THIS PROCESS
FORWARD WE ASK YOU ABOUT.
ANY OTHER MEMBERS THE PUBLIC
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
THE OFFICE BILL -- DANIEL
BROUGHT ON BEHALF OF SIERRA CLUB
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER MEMBERS THE
PUBLIC'S RIGHT TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OR HAVE CONCERNS OF
THE AUTHORS BILL.
SEEING NONE ANY QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE OF THE AUTHOR.
QUESTION OF RIGHT.
THIS BILL WOULD MISTER HALL HOW
DO YOU -- HOW DO YOU THINK THIS
WILL IMPACT THE FUTURE CAPACITY
OF THE SEVEN TEN TAKING THE
TUNNEL PROJECT OFF THE TABLE IN
A SENSE?
WELL I THINK THAT WHAT WE
RECOGNIZE THE CALTRANS AND LA
METRO WE'RE BASICALLY GIVING
SOME DIRECTIONS AROUND A VARIETY
OF OPTIONS -- OBVIOUSLY PEOPLE
IN THE COMMUNITY HAVE THEIR
VARIOUS IDEAS OF WHAT WOULD BE
THE BEST SOLUTION BUT THE ONE
THAT.
HAS UNANIMOUS WERE NEAR
UNANIMOUS SUPPORT IS THE
ALTERNATIVE THAT WAS SELECTED --
BY CALTRANS AND ULTIMATELY --
ENDORSED BY -- SELECTED BY METRO
AND CULTURE AND SO WE HAVE -- AN
APPROACH THAT I THINK IT BRINGS.
UNITY TO EVERYONE IN TERMS OF
THE IMPACT ON THE AREA I CAN
ONLY TELL YOU WHAT THE IMPACT
HAS BEEN ON THE SURROUNDING AREA.
FOR ALL THESE MANY YEARS AND
IT'S BEEN -- VERY MUCH -- AN
IMPACTED THIS DEVASTATED AREA
BUT AT THE SAME TIME THE
SOLUTIONS THAT ARE WE'RE
PURSUING I THINK ARE GOING TO
BREAK THE RIGHT KIND OF HARMONY.
AND MOVEMENT OF TRAFFIC AND
THERE CAN THE RIGHT WAY.
THANK YOU HI I APPRECIATE THAT
THAT'S ALWAYS A TUG.
THE TUSSLING THAT'S GOING ON
WITH LOCALS IN THE STATE ON MANY
OF OUR PROJECTS BECAUSE A LOCAL
SEE IT ONE WAY AND THE STATE
SEASON ANOTHER SO THAT BRINGS UP
THE SECOND QUESTION WHICH WOULD
BE.
HOW DO WE FOCUS ON THE FACT THAT
WE HAVE AN EVER INCREASING
CAPACITY NEED FOR MANY OF THE
HIGHWAY SEVENTEEN BEING ONE OF
THOSE AND WE'RE NOW?
GONNA HAVE A BOTTLE NECK.
ESSENTIALLY IN THAT THAT AREA
THAT WE'RE REFERRING TO HERE.
YEAH WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
PROJECTS STILL ON THE
CONSTRUCTION CORD OF CALTRANS
MISSION TO INCREASE CAPACITY ON
THE SEVENTY AND THAT WILL CAUSE.
A RESTRICTION THAT WILL BE
IMPACTED BY NOW THIS RESTRICTING
AREA SO MY CONCERN IS JUST.
HAVE WE TALKED ENOUGH WITH
CALTRANS ABOUT THEIR FUTURES FOR
THE SEVEN TEN AS A WHOLE AND
WHAT IS THE LAND MANAGEMENT
PRACTICE OF THE LOCALS.
AS YOU SAID SOME OF THIS IS
GOING.
TO BE UNITS ON THIS LAND WE
UTILIZE FOR GROWTH POTENTIAL YET
THE HIGHWAY WON'T BE ABLE TO
HANDLE THAT GROWS SO WHERE HOW
DO WE RESOLVE THAT CONFLICT AND
FUTURE PLANNING.
I DON'T MEAN TO INTERRUPT.
I KNOW THAT WAS A VERY LENGTHY
QUESTIONS WE WANT TO GIVE YOU AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME TO BE ABLE
TO THINK ABOUT AN ANSWER BUT I
NEED TO GO FROM.
THAT SECRETARY WILL YOU PLEASE
CALL [inaudible]
FRAZIER [inaudible]
FONG.
AND YOUR CURRY [inaudible]
BERMAN [inaudible]
BIGELOW [inaudible]
CHIU [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
DALY.
DEEP HERE.
FRIEDMAN [inaudible]
GIPSON [inaudible]
GRAYSON [inaudible]
MEDINA.
IS THERE IN [inaudible]
O'DONNELL.
WE HAVE A QUORUM SO WE'LL MOVE
FORWARD -- TO YOUR ABILITY TO
ANSWER THE QUESTION MISTER
BIGELOW.
PLEASE PROCEED YES THANK YOU
RESEARCHER -- KILLER CLEARLY
CALTRANS DID AN EXHAUSTIVE
REVIEW AND STUDY OF THE PROJECTS
THE ALTERNATIVES THAT WERE IN
FRONT OF THEM -- THEY CONCURRED
WITH LA METRO THE LOCAL RATES
ORIGINAL AGENCY.
SO THERE UNDERSTANDING WHAT
NEEDS TO BE DONE THE
ALTERNATIVES ARE DESIGNED TO
CONTINUE TO CREATE EFFECTIVE AND
EFFICIENT MOVEMENT OF TRAFFIC
THROUGH THE AREA.
BUT DOING AND ONE THAT IS
RESPECTING SO THE MOVEMENT --
THAT WE SEE -- WE'RE TRYING TO
GET PEOPLE OUT OF THEIR CARS
RIGHT SO YES THIS CAPACITY BUT
THERE'S ALSO -- THE RECOGNITION
THAT WE'RE LOOKING AT LIGHT RAIL
PROJECTS AND MOVING PEOPLE
THROUGH PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION --
COLLECT CONNECTING THE REGION
AND AND A MORE SYNCHRONIZE AN
APPROPRIATE WAY WE'RE WORKING
WITH CALTRANS -- AND WE'RE ALSO
WORKING WITH METRO -- AND SAN
DIEGO COUNTY TO EXTEND LIGHT
RAIL OUT INTO THE SAMBAR DEER
COUNTY OR SO THERE'S A
RECOGNITION THAT WE NEED TO DO
MORE. TO ADDRESS THE ISSUE OF
CAPACITY RIGHT NOW YOU HAVE CARS
THAT ARE SITTING ON THE PARK ON
THESE FREEWAYS IN THEIR PARKING
LOTS.
AND SO WE GOT TO DO A BETTER JOB
OF OF MOVING PEOPLE AROUND THE
REGION WE HAVE TO DO IT IN A WAY
THAT'S RESPECTFUL TO
ENVIRONMENTAL POLICIES THAT THE
STATE HAS EMBARKED ON THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I APPRECIATE THAT.
WELL THE FIRST BY MISTER GIBSON
SECOND BY A YEAR CURRY -- ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE
OF THE AUTHOR.
SIGNAL.
MR ALWAYS LIKE CLOSE.
YES I JUST LIKE TO SAY A
PERSONAL THANK YOU TO YOU MISTER
CHAIR BECAUSE OVER THE LAST
COUPLE OF YEARS SO WE'VE.
BEEN WORKING THIS BILL AND ONE
CONFIGURATION OR ANOTHER YOU'VE
ALWAYS BEEN.
SUPPORTIVE IN TERMS OF THE OF
ALLOWING ME TO HAVE THE RIGHT.
AVENUE TO PROCEED YOU'VE ALWAYS
BEEN INSTRUCTIVE AND THE BEST
WAY TO MOVE FORWARD -- AND I DO
APPRECIATE THE SUPPORT OF THIS
COMMITTEE -- WELL AS I SAID
BEFORE THIS BILL I STAND HERE
BEFORE YOU TODAY WHEN THERE'S NO
OPPOSITION. TO THIS BILL AND
THAT IS TAKE A LITTLE BIT OF
TIME TO GET THERE BUT APPRECIATE
YOUR INDULGENCE AND ALLOWING US.
TO MAKE OUR WAY THROUGH THAT
PROCESS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
DRIVER.
THANK YOU MISTER GOLDMAN AND IT
HAS BEEN A PLEASURE WORKING WITH
YOU ON THIS OF ON A PROJECT THAT
WAS NEVER AFFORDABLE IN THE
FIRST PLACE AND AND YOU'RE
TAKING A REASONABLE APPROACH IN.
ADDRESSING ALL OF THE CONCERNS
OF THE INDIVIDUALS THAT APPROACH
BOTH OF US -- I CAN'T THANK YOU
ENOUGH FOR DOING THAT AND AND
THE PATIENTS THAT YOU'VE HAD.
IN DOIG SO.
AND SO YOU KNOW IT'S BEEN A LONG
CHALLENGING PROCESS -- AND AND
SEVEN TEN IN PASADENA AND I'M
GLAD WE'VE REACHED TO A POINT
WHERE THERE'S AN END.
AND WITH THAT I'LL BE SUPPORTING
YOUR BILL TODAY I HAVE SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
FRAZIER [inaudible]
FONG [inaudible]
AGUIAR-CURRY [inaudible]
BERMAN [inaudible]
BIGELOW.
ACTUALLY UP TOWARD.
I THINK EARLY ON THE UNITED
[inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
CHAIR [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
DALY.
DEEP.
NOT VOTING [inaudible]
FRIEDMAN [inaudible]
GIPSON GLORIA [inaudible]
GRAYSON [inaudible]
MEDINA [inaudible]
NAZARIAN [inaudible]
O'DONNELL.
SO LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FRANK THE
ABSENT MEMBERS AND WILL MOVE
FORWARD.
BAKER MISSION THANK YOU SIR.
SORENESS AUTHOR WOULD BE --
LET'S GO ON AGAIN I'VE BEEN
REMINDED WE NEED TO CATCH UP ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
SO THE FIRST IMAGE BELOW SECOND
BY MISTER GIBSON OF MATTER SIR
TO PLEASE CALL THE ROLL FOR THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR FRAZIER
[inaudible]
FONG HI [inaudible]
AGUIAR-CURRY [inaudible]
BERMAN [inaudible]
BIGELOW I'VE [inaudible]
CHIU [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
DALY [inaudible]
DAVE [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
FRIEDMAN [inaudible]
GIPSON [inaudible]
GRAYSON [inaudible]
MEDINA [inaudible]
NAZARIAN [inaudible]
O'DONNELL.
SO WITH THAT ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS WHO FORD.
OF ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK SILVA TO
PLEASE.
PUSH THE AND PLEASE START WHEN
YOU'RE READY GOOD AFTERNOON
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS TODAY AND PRESENTING A.
B. TWO SIXTY NINE WHICH WAVES
THE PRACTICAL PORTION OF THE
DRIVER'S TEST WHEN APPLYING FOR
A CALIFORNIA DRIVER'S LICENSE
FOR THOSE CALIFORNIANS ALREADY
IN POSSESSION OF A VALID. FOR A
FOREIGN DRIVERS LICENSE UNDER
CALIFORNIA LAW.
AS WAS NOTED BEFORE WITH THE
PREVIOUS SPEAKER PATIENCE IS A
VIRTUE AND THIS.
AS A SPECIFIC LEGISLATION HAS
BEEN TALKED ABOUT AND MOVE
FORWARD AND ANALYZE.
SEVERAL TIMES AND WE ARE HOPING
THAT THIS TIME WILL BE THE TIME
WILL YOU WILL SAY YES.
EXISTING LAW ENABLES THOSE
INDIVIDUALS AND POSSESSION OF OF
A VALID FOREIGN.
LICENSE DETERMINED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF THE DMV TO DRIVING
CALIFORNIA'S ROADS AND HIGHWAYS.
THIS BILL EXTENDS THIS POLICY O
ENSURE THE SAME DRIVERS ARE ALSO
FREE AND CLEAR TO GET A
CALIFORNIA DRIVER'S LICENSE AS
READILY AS THEY ARE ABLE THIS IS
A MATTER OF MAKING SURE WE HAVE
UNIFORMITY.
AMONG DRIVERS AND THAT THEY ARE
FAMILIAR WITH THE SPECIFICS OF
CALIFORNIA TRAFFIC LAWS.
AUTHORIZING THE DMB TO SIGN
RECIPROCAL MEMORANDUMS OF
UNDERSTANDING WITH THOSE
COUNTRIES WITH WHOM WE SHARE
SAFE DRIVING STANDARDS IS AN ACT
OF GOOD WILL TOWARDS AYE OUT OUR
TRADE PARTNERS AND ALLIES --
TODAY I HAVE WITH ME HAWKS SO
RUE WHO IS IN SUPPORT.
PLEASE TEACH NAMELY REPRESENTING
PLEASE.
THAT.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I FEEL
PRIVILEGE IT TO SIT HERE ON
BEHALF OF QUICK KOREAN
GOVERNMENT.
I SINCERELY SUPPORT AB TWO SIX
NINE ONE WRIST PROCAR TRIBAL
LICENSE PROGRAM.
I AM PERSONALLY AWARE OF THE
BENEFITS FROM THIS MUTUAL
RECOGNITION OF TRIBAL LICENSE.
AS A DIPLOMAT.
MY DRIVER LICENSE FEE EACH I HAD
RECEIVED IN KOREA EATS
RECOGNIZED IN MANY COUNTRIES
INCLUDING THE UNITED STATES.
SO I ENJOY DRIVING IN CALIFORNIA
AND ACTUALLY TO ATTEND THIS
COMMITTEE MEETING I TOLD.
ALL THE WAY FROM LOS ANGELES TO
SACRAMENTO THIS MORNING.
AND THOUGHT OF THE BENEFITS THIS
MUTUAL RECOGNITION SYSTEM CAN
MAKE. TWO EIGHTY CALIFORNIANS
AND FOURTEEN OTHERS WHO'VE VISIT
DISCORDANCE PAID.
INCLUDING KOREA.
HAVING SAID THAT THIS IS TEN
GIVES MANY BENEFITS TO THE
CALIFORNIANS AND THE GOVERNMENT
FIRST.
THE CALIFORNIANS WHO VISIT
FOREIGN COUNTRIES AND STAYED
THERE CAN ENJOY DRIVING CARDS.
WITHOUT TAKING EXAMINATIONS.
SECOND.
WHEN THIS IS TEN EIGHTY
STABILISED THE TEMPORARY
ARE NOT REQUIRED? TO THE PAY CUT
DRIVING PAST ON DOUBLE.
FEATURE WE ARE REMARKABLY REDUCE
THE BURDEN OF PM PLEASE WORK.
THOUGHT WHEN FOREIGNERS MOVED TO
CALIFORNIA THEY NEED TO
FACILITATE THE PROCESS OF THE
STEP IN MONTH BY GETTING DEPRIVE
WHAT'S LICENSE.
IF THIS MUTUAL SYSTEM BECOMES IN
THE FACT THEIR LIFE CAN BE MORE
CONVENIENT AND THE CALIFORNIA
CAN BE MORE ATTRACTIVE TO
FOURTEEN VISITORS AND INVESTORS.
FOR EXAMPLE KOREA IS THE SIXTH
LARGEST TRADING PARTNER TO
CALIFORNIA.
AND THE THOUGHT BIGGEST PARKED
NOT TO LOS ANGELES
IF THIS BILL IS APPROVED.
KOREAN PEOPLE AND COMPANY WILL
FEEL THE CALIFORNIA CLOSER
EMOTIONALLY AND PHYSICALLY.
LAST BUT NOT LEAST.
IT'S STILL MAINTAINS THE PARTY
OF THE DRIVING SECURITY.
BECAUSE IT IS NOT RELATED TO THE
INSURANCE.
STILL THE FORTY IN VISITOR IS
REQUIRED TO ATTEND ON INSURANCE
TO THRIVE OR RENTAL CAR.
YOUR CHAIRMAN AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
I RECEIVED THIRTY ONE SUPPORTER
LETTERS FROM MANY KOREANS AND
KOREAN GROUPS OR NEED.
DURING ONLY FOR TWO DAYS.
OKAY AS AN AMERICAN ONE THIS
PROGRAM AND SUPPORTED.
WE ALSO WISH THIS BILL PASSED IN
THE NEAR FUTURE.
THANK YOU FOR GIVING ME THIS
FLOOR.
THANK YOU FOR THAT SIR.
ANY OTHER MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TO LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
THE AUTHORS BILL.
MOVE THE BILL.
ANY OTHER MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
THAT WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL OR HAVE
CONCERNS WITH THE AUTHORS BILL.
THE STEP UP TO THE MIKE.
I AM MY NAME IS KIM CHAMBERLAIN.
I AM REPRESENTING KOREAN
AMERICAN ASSOCIATION OF A SHASTA.
AND ALSO AMERICAN VETERANS
ADVOCATE.
I AM IN SUPPORT OF THE CASE
BILLS.
IVORY GEO TOOL CAST TO GOOD FOR
TODAY. TO MAKE IT SO MANY KOREAN
ARE PEOPLE WHO WILL BE SAID IT
GOLDEN STATE THEIR LIFE MUCH
EASIER.
AND ALSO.
CALIFORNIA WILL BENEFIT PUT
THERE VISITING.
AND DRIVING.
A PRIVILEGE THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU MA'AM.
SO WE'LL TRY IT ONE MORE TIME AS
FAR AS FOR MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TO LIKE TO TRACK TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OR CONCERNS OF THE
AUTHORS BILL.
SEEING NONE.
OF A BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ANY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS HAVE MISTER
BIGELOW BEFORE QUESTIONS AND I
AM.
WHEN I THINK THE AUTHOR FOR THE?
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESSES BILL IN
THE CHAIR.
MY CONCERN -- MY QUESTION IS.
WITH RESPECT TO THIS BILL IT IT
RIVER REALLY REFERS TO A LIKE
KIND.
TYPE OF TESTING BUT IT DOESN'T
REALLY ADDRESS THE FACT THAT
THERE ARE DIFFERENCES.
OF RULES OF THE ROAD.
ON MEANING SEVENTY FIVE
COUNTRIES IN THE WORLD DRIVE ON
THE LEFT WHERE AS A HUNDRED
SIXTY FIVE DRIVE ON THE RIGHT.
THERE'S A BIG DIFFERENCE AND
THERE IS A CURVE CHANGE HOW DOES
THIS BILL ANTICIPATE ADDRESSING
THAT.
THAT CHANGE FOR THOSE PEOPLE
HAVE THE DIFFERENCE.
TYPE OF LICENSING. FOR EXAMPLE
IS THE PEOPLE WHO SPOKE HERE
TODAY SPOKE FROM KOREA.
AND THEY DRIVE ON THE RIGHT BUT
WHAT ABOUT THE PEOPLE FROM THE
U. K. AND MANY OF THESE OTHER
COUNTRIES.
THE SEVENTY FIVE DOLLARS FOR THE
THE DRIVE ON THE LEFT AND WE
SEEN MANY PEOPLE COME TO THIS
COUNTRY.
ACTUALLY HAVE ACCIDENTS WERE
ACTUALLY I'VE BEEN ONE OF THOSE
ATTENDING EMTS VOTE BECAUSE
EIGHTY STE.
LOST TRACK OF THEIR PRESENCE AND
THREE DRIVING ON THE LEFT AGAIN.
CALLING AHEAD ON SO HOW DO WE
REMEDY THAT TO MAKE SURE WE'RE
ADDRESSING IT.
WELL I THINK FIRST OF ALL
WHETHER YOUR FROM OUR COUNTRY OR
CALIFORNIA -- THAT WHETHER YOU.
HAVE PASSED OUR TESTS THAT STILL
DOESN'T.
ELIMINATE ANY ACCIDENTS WE SEE
MANY MANY AMERICANS IN ACCIDENTS
EVERY DOWN BUT AS FAR AS FOREIGN
COUNTRIES IT'S JUST IT'S LOOKING
AT THE UNIFORMITY AMONG THE
STANDARDS WHICH IS WHY THIS WAS
BROUGHT.
FOR FORWARD AS FAR AS MAKING
SURE THERE'S AT LEAST A OF
COMMON -- RULES TO THE ROAD IF
YOU WANT TO SAY IT THAT WAY --
THAT THEY HAVE ALREADY SHOWING
THAT THEY HAVE PASSED BY.
GAINING THEIR LICENSE IN THE
COUNTRY THAT THEY'RE AT BUT I DO
AGREE WITH YOU THE RIGHT AND
LEFT ON BUT IT IS LIKE WHEN WE
GO TO ANOTHER COUNTRY.
OURSELVES AND WE RENT A CAR
THERE'S THERE'S OBVIOUSLY SOME
DIFFERENCES BUT AS THOSE
INDIVIDUALS GET INTO THE CAR
RENT THE CAR SIGN ALL THE
INSURANCE AGREEMENTS I THINK
THEY ARE NOTING THAT THEY'RE
GOING TO BE EXTREMELY.
CAREFUL IN STARTING OUT.
JUST LIKE A YOUNG DRIVER WOULD --
WHETHER THERE'S SIXTEEN OR
EIGHTEEN SO DOES NOT ENSURE THAT
THEY WOULD NEVER BE AN ACCIDENT
BUT I THINK.
THERE'S SOME ON BASIC -- AS WE
SAY UNIFORMITY THAT WERE SEEN IN
ALL COUNTRIES WITH DRIVING PRIME
BUT AND I AGREE WITH THAT
COMPONENT THE BASICS.
WHAT I HAVE A QUESTION ABOUT IS
REALLY THE RULES OF THE ROAD
WHICH THERE ARE SIGNIFICANT
DIFFERENCES?
OF FROM SIDE TO SIDE SO THAT
THAT WAS MY REAL CONCERN WITH
RESPECT TO THAT AS IT IS TODAY
UNDER THE LAWS.
WHETHER YOU'RE FROM OREGON
NEVADA ARIZONA.
AFTER YOU ESTABLISH RESIDENCY
HERE IN.
CALIFORNIA YOU HAVE TEN DAYS TO
GET A DRIVER'S LICENSE AND BUT
YOU HAVE A COMMONALITY OF YOUR
ACCEPTED AND DEEMED TO HAVE HAD
A TAKING A TEST.
WHEN YOU GOT YOUR LICENSE OR SO
YOU DON'T HAVE TO TAKE A DRIVING
BUT IF YOU COME FROM MEXICO OR
SOMEBODY THAT'S CLOSE TO US?
THEN IT IS REQUIRED SO I
UNDERSTAND WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO
ACCOMPLISH WHAT I MY CONCERN IS
THE RULES OF THE ROAD LONG TERM
FROM.
DIFFERENT COUNTRIES SO.
THANK YOU THANK CRESCENTA MISTER
BIGELOW I MIGHT ADD THOUGH IT
FOR THEIR VISITING FROM ANOTHER
COUNTRY THEY DON'T HAVE TO TAKE
ANY TEST AND HAVE THE ABILITY TO
START DRIVING RIGHT AWAY.
AND SO IS THAT BEING SAID THIS
ISN'T THIS ISN'T BACK AND FORTH --
SO THAT BEING SAID -- WHEN THEY
BECOME A PERMANENT RESIDENT
THAT'S WHEN THIS COMES IN EFFECT
BUT THEY ALREADY HAVE THE
ABILITY TO DRIVE OUR ROADS?
REGARDLESS SO -- WITH THAT ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING THEM ASSEMBLYMEMBER WHICH
LIKE TO CLOSE I JUST I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU -- WITH THAT -- WE
HAVE FIRST PLAYED A AND YOUR
CURRY SECOND BY GRAYSON -- I
WANT TO THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD.
IN THINKING ABOUT -- AGAIN A
KNOWLEDGE IN THE CALIFORNIA IS
OPEN FOR BUSINESS.
AND MAKING SURE THAT -- WE LEAVE
NO TOOLS LEFT IN THE TOOL BOX WE
CLOSE.
TO SHARING THAT OF PERSPECTIVE
AND WHAT THAT'LL BE SECURING
YOUR I'LL BE SUPPORTING OF THEIR
BILL TODAY AND MATTER OF SUCH
SECTOR PLEASE CALL ROLE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
FRAZIER [inaudible]
FONG [inaudible]
AGUIAR-CURRY [inaudible]
BERMAN [inaudible]
BIGELOW [inaudible]
CHAIR [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM.
THERE IS A DAILY [inaudible]
DEEP I FRIEDMAN.
GIPSON R. GRAYSON [inaudible]
MEDINA [inaudible]
NAZARIAN [inaudible]
O'DONNELL.
SO LEAVE WROTE THE ROLE BUT FROM
SOME MEMBERS -- THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PRESENTATION.
YOU MEMBERS SO I'M GONNA HAND
THE GAVEL OVER TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FONG.
I'LL BE PRESENTING.
EIGHTY THREE
NINETY I WITH THAT MISTER
CHAIRMAN HE CAN BEGIN AT A TIME.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
AB THREE THREE NINETY IS A VERY
SIMPLE BILL. EIGHTY THREE NINETY
RESTORES THE ABILITY FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO ISSUE CORRECTABLE
CITATIONS.
OR FIX IT TICKETS. TO MORE
STRIVING MOTOR VEHICLES THAT ARE
EQUIPPED WITH EXHAUST SYSTEMS
THAT ARE SUSPECTED OF VIOLATING
CALIFORNIA'S. 95% DECIBEL NOISE
LAW OR NON FUNCTIONING MUFFLERS.
UNDER EXISTING LAW IF A MOTORIST.
MOTORCYCLE WERE AUTOMOBILE IS
STOP FOR PERCEIVED EXCESS OF
EXHAUST NOISE.
LAW ENFORCEMENT HAS ONLY TWO
OPTIONS.
THE FIRST IS LET THE PERSON GO
WITH JUST A WARNING.
THE SECOND AND AND ONLY OTHER
OPTION IS TO ISSUE A TICKET
WHICH RESULTS IN A OFTENTIMES
COSTLY FINE.
AND COURT APPEARANCE.
RESTORING THE OPEN OFFICERS
THIRD OPTION THE FIX IT TICKET.
ALLOWS THE MOTORS TO REPAIR THE
PROBLEM AND GET BACK INTO
COMPLIANCE.
WITHOUT HAVING TO PAY EXCESSIVE
FINES.
THIS OPTION IS EXPRESSLY PORTENT
FOR THOSE WHO CANNOT AFFORD
EXPENSIVE PENALTIES.
SEVERAL SEVERAL HUNDREDS OF
DOLLARS FOR EXAMPLE.
AND TAKE TIME OFF OF CORD OFF
FOR COURT APPEARANCES.
THIS IS A COMMON SENSE BILL THAT
IS CO SPONSORED BY THE SPECIAL
EQUIPMENT MANUFACTURERS
ASSOCIATION WHICH WILL.
ONLY KNOW SEMA.
AND THE WESTERN CENTER OF OF OF
LAW AND POVERTY.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THAT WOULD TO WITH ME TODAY
I HAVE CHRISTIAN ROBINSON FROM
SEEMING TO SPEAK IN.
SUPPORT OF THE BILL AND ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE
[inaudible]
PLEASE PROCEED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN --
MY NAME IS CHRISTIAN ROBINSON
AND I AM THE DIRECTOR STATE
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS AT SEMA OR
THE SPECIALTY EQUIPMENT MARKET
ASSOCIATION.
WHICH IS HEADQUARTERED IN
DIAMOND BAR CALIFORNIA.
SEEM AS A NATIONAL TRADE
ASSOCIATION THAT REPRESENTS MORE
THAN SEVENTY FIVE HUNDRED MOSTLY
SMALL BUSINESSES INCLUDING OVER
SEVENTEEN HUNDRED AND THE GOLDEN
STATE.
THE MANUFACTURE MARKET AND SELL
SPECIALTY AUTOMOTIVE AFTERMARKET
PRODUCTS.
ALSO THE SEMA SHOW WHICH IS
HOSTED EVERY YEAR IN LAS VEGAS
NEVADA.
IS THE LARGEST ANNUAL GATHERING
A SMALL BUSINESSES IN THE
COUNTRY.
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN INDUSTRY
SALES REACHED A NEW HIGH OF
FORTY THREE BILLION DOLLARS FOR
THE ASSOCIATION.
OF THIS TOTAL EXHAUST RELATED
PRODUCTS REPRESENT THREE POINT
ONE THREE BILLION DOLLARS.
THIS IS EXPECTED TO GROW TO
THREE AND A QUARTER BILLION
DOLLARS.
FOR TWENTY EIGHTEEN HOWEVER THE
CONFUSION CREATED OVER THE
CURRENT PROCESS FOR ISSUING
CITATIONS FOR EXCESSIVE NOISE
AND BROKEN MUFFLERS.
AS HAMPER THE ABILITY OF OUR
MEMBERS -- TO SELL THEIR
PRODUCTS AND COULD STAGNATE THAT
GROWTH TO ASSERT JUST REFERRED.
SEEM AS RECEIVED DOZENS OF
LETTERS FROM CONCERNED MEMBER
COMPANIES REQUESTING THAT
MEMBERS SHOULD BE TO TAKE ACTION.
AND HUNDREDS MORE FROM CONSUMERS
AND ENTHUSIASTS AROUND THE
COUNTRY AND IN CALIFORNIA.
WELL THE VAST MAJORITY ARE
LOCATED HERE IN CALIFORNIA WE'VE
HEARD FROM IMPACTED COMPANIES AS
FAR AWAY AS PENNSYLVANIA NORTH
CAROLINA CANADA.
AND EVEN JAPAN.
THESE RANGE FROM MAJOR BRANDS
HIS PARTS CAN BE FOUND ON CARS
MADE BY GENERAL MOTORS FORD AND
HONDA. TO SMALL SHOPS THAT
EMPLOYEE JUST A HANDFUL OF
CALIFORNIANS.
AB EIGHTEEN TWENTY FOUR WHICH IS
WHAT WE'RE LOOKING TO CORRECT
JUST ON A WRENCH INTO A ONCE
WORKING COMPLIANCE PROCESS AND
LED TO WIDESPREAD PERCEPTION.
AMONGST CONSUMERS OF A GUILTY
UNTIL PROVEN INNOCENT STANDARD
FOR MOTORIST.
THE PASSAGE OF AB THREE NINETY
IS THE ONLY WAY TO RESTORE
CONFIDENCE IN THIS MULTI BILLION
DOLLAR MARKET PLACE.
AND FOR THIS REASON I ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE.
I THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND AS
THE CHAIRMAN MENTIONED BE HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY FOLLOW UP
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE.
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS IT COMMITTEE
JAMES EMBARRASSING YOUR BEHALF
OF THE BETA CALIFORNIA
MOTORCYCLE RIGHTS AND SAFETY
ORGANIZATION.
AND CALIFORNIA RECYCLE DEALERS
ASSOCIATION WHO SUPPORT THE BILL
AS WE GO DOWN THE ROAD WE CAN
PICK UP ALL KINDS OF THINGS THAT
HAD OUR MUFFLERS AND BECAUSE OF
THE DAMAGE -- A FIX THE TICKET
THIS BEEN IN EFFECT SINCE
NINETEEN SEVENTY EIGHT HAS BEEN
VERY EFFECTIVE ON US GOING IN
CORRECTING THIS WITHOUT MAJOR
COST THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU -- YES MY CAROL WITH
THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY -- WE ALSO STAND SUPPORT
OF AB -- THREE NINETY AS YOU
KNOW I WE'VE BEEN FOR THIS MANY
MANY TIMES TALKING ABOUT THE
HIGH COST OF TRAFFIC TICKETS
PARKING TICKETS WE MADE A LOT OF
PROGRESS IN THIS ARENA IN RECENT
YEARS.
WE STE WE VIEW THIS AS A
UNNECESSARY CORRECTIVE ACTION TO
GET THAT BACK TO A FIX IT TAKE
IT MAKE MAKE SURE THAT THE CAR.
GETS THE LICENSE OF THE MUFFLER
FIXED AND NOT END UP HAVING
SOMEONE GETTING A TICKET THE
TURNS FROM.
A TWENTY FIVE DOLLAR TICKET INTO
A FIVE HUNDRED DOLLAR TICKET
OVERNIGHT SO WE SUPPORT THE BILL
THANK YOU.
AT THE VERY MUCH OF ANY
ADDITIONAL -- SUPPORTERS THE POP
FROM THE PUBLIC.
SCENE NINE ANY IN THE PUBLIC
THAT WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE ANY QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE.
AS SEEN ON I'M SHOWS THAT CLOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN.
THE FIRST I'D LIKE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE AND MOST OF US AND
HAVE COME FROM LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
AND YOU LOOK AT HOW CONSTRAINED
OUR POLICE DEPARTMENTS ARE
NUMBER ONE WE KNOW THAT WE HAVE
A THOUSAND OF POLICE OFFICERS
SHORT IN THE CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY
PATROL BUT YET.
THIS IS THIS IS AN ACTION IT
WOULD TAKE.
A LOT OF MANPOWER TO DRAW
PROBABLY TRY TO ENFORCE THOSE OF
ALL THE RIGHT ONES THAT I'VE
EVER DONE.
ON THE PUBLIC SAFETY IN MY IN MY
DISTRICT I'M NOT SEEN ONE POLICE
OFFICER CARRIER.
A DECIBEL METER -- GOING FORWARD
SO YOU KNOW IT'S KIND OF COMMON
SENSE TO GO BACK TO THE APPROACH
WHERE WE WERE -- AND I'M.
LOOKING FORWARD TO A AN IPHONE
THANK YOU.
I THINK YOU MIGHT BE VERY MUCH I
THINK WE HAVE A FIRST MISTER
GRAYSON AND OF MISTER GIBSON HAS
SECOND MISTER BERMAN.
AT SOME ANSWER TO PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL [inaudible]
FRAZIER [inaudible]
FONG BY.
AND YOUR CURRY [inaudible]
BERMAN [inaudible]
BIGELOW [inaudible]
Q. [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
DALY [inaudible]
DEEP HI [inaudible]
FRIEDMAN [inaudible]
GIPSON HI [inaudible]
RECENT [inaudible]
MEDINA [inaudible]
NAZARIAN [inaudible]
O'DONNELL.
WE'LL LEAVE THAT OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS.
THANK YOU
.
WE WILL MOVE ON TO AB TWO EIGHTY
FIVE SO MA'AM FRIEDMAN. TO THE
PODIUM.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR WORKING WITH ME ON
THIS POLICY.
THANK YOU AB HOW MUCH DO YOU
WANT ME 2% OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU TRANSPORTATION
CONTINUES TO BE CALIFORNIA'S
GREATEST CONTRIBUTOR TO
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS.
DIRECT EMISSIONS FROM THE TAIL
PIPES OF CARS TRUCKS OFFER A
TRANSPORTATION SOURCES AND MORE
ACCOUNTED FOR MORE THAN 39% OF
THE GHG INVENTORY IN.
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN A 2%
INCREASE FROM.
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN AB TWO
EIGHTY FIVE REQUIRES THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
TRANSPORTATION TO INCORPORATE
THE CURRENT GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS REDUCTION GOALS.
SUCH AS SB THIRTY TWO AND THE
STATE'S AIR QUALITY PLANS INTO
THE CALIFORNIA TRANSPORTATION
PLAN.
DATA FROM A CALIFORNIA'S
SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITIES AND
CLIMATE PROTECTION ACT TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN PROGRESS
REPORT INDICATES THAT CALIFORNIA
IS NOT ON THE TRAJECTORY TO ME
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSION
REDUCTION TARGETS.
FROM THE AUTOMOBILES AND LIGHT
TRUCKS SECTOR.
FOR TWO THOUSAND TWENTY AND
THIRTY FIVE TWO THOUSAND THIRTY
FIVE OUR AGENCIES HAVE TO WORK
TOGETHER IN ORDER TO IMPLEMENT
OUR PLANS AND ATTAIN OR
TRANSPORTATION AND ENVIRONMENTAL
GOALS.
AB TWO EIGHTY FIVE ALSO REQUIRES
A REVIEW TO IMPROVE COORDINATION
OF THE SIX A STABLE COMMUNITIES
GRANT PROGRAMS A FORECAST OF THE
IMPACTS OF ADVANCE AN EMERGING
TECHNOLOGIES.
AND ADDS ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
TO THE SUBJECT AREAS THAT THE
PLAN CONSIDERS.
THIS UPDATE TO CALIFORNIA'S LONG
TERM TRANSPORTATION PLANNING.
WILL IMPROVE THE EFFECTIVENESS
OF TRANSPORTATION EMISSION
REDUCTION PROGRAMS WITH ME TODAY
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS ROCKY
RUSHING WITH THE CALIPHATE WITH
THE COALITION FOR CLEAN AIR WITH
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
THIS PROCEDURE.
GOOD AFTERNOON I MEAN MEMBERS.
MY NAME IS ROCKY RESCUE WITH
COALITION FOR CLEAN AIR.
DARVEL ENVIRONMENTAL AND HEALTH
IMPACTS OF TAILPIPE EMISSIONS
ARE IRREFUTABLE WHETHER IT'S MOM
OR DAD SOCCER VAN A DELIVERY
TRUCK WRAPPING UP PACKAGES IN
OUR NEIGHBORHOODS.
OR EIGHTEEN WHEELER ROLLING DOWN
THE INTERSTATE WE ARE PUMPING
TOXIC CHEMICALS IN WIRE THAT ARE
HEATING UP OUR CLIMATE MAKING
PEOPLE SICK.
TRANSPORTATION SOURCES ACCOUNT
FOR APPROXIMATELY 80% SMOG
FORMING KNOCKS EMISSIONS 90% OF
DIESEL PM AND APPROXIMATELY HALF
OF OUR GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS.
IN CALIFORNIA.
THESE POLLUTANTS IMPACT AIR
QUALITY IN LOCAL COMMUNITIES
CONTRIBUTING TO A WIDE RANGE OF
NAY NEGATIVE HEALTH OUTCOMES
INCLUDING AS MY TAX.
ER VISITS AND HOSPITALIZATIONS
HEART ATTACKS STROKES AND EVEN
PREMATURE DEATH.
CARBONPOLLUTION FROM OUR
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM CRASH
CLIMATE CHANGE HEALTH IMPACTS
AND CONDITIONS FOR EXTREME HEAT
DROUGHT AND WILDFIRE WE ALL
REMEMBER OUR SUMMER OF SMOKE.
YET THERE'S A SERIOUS DISCONNECT
WITH THE AIR QUALITY IN CLIMB
GOLD AND ARE TRANSPORTATION
PLANNING.
WE KNOW WE WILL MISS OUR TWENTY
THIRTY GHG REDUCTION TARGET
UNLESS WE SOLVE THE
TRANSPORTATION HOUSING.
PLANNING CONUNDRUM COALITION
CLEAN AIR SUPPORT AB TWO EIGHTY
FIVE AND THANKED THE AUTHOR.
BECAUSE IT SEEKS TO ENSURE THAT
CURRENT CLEAN ERA CLIMATE
STANDARDS ARE ACCOUNTED FOR IN
THE CALIFORNIA TRANSPORTATION
PLAN.
AB TWENTY FIVE WOULD REQUIRE
CALTRANS TO ADDRESS HOW WE WILL
REACH EMISSION REDUCTIONS
NECESSARY TO MEET CLEAN AIR ACT
REQUIREMENTS.
CALIFORNIA'S TWENTY THIRTY
CLIMATE STANDARDS IN FUTURE
TRANSPORTATION PLANS THERE IS A
CRITICAL NEED TO ENSURE THAT
CALIFORNIA'S TRANSPORTATION
DECISIONS INVESTMENT SUPPORT.
REDUCTIONS IN POLLUTANTS THAT
THREATEN THE HEALTH OF TOO MANY
CALIFORNIANS AB TWENTY FIVE
WOULD PLAY AN IMPORTANT ROLE IN
LEADING THIS NEED THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER MEMBERS OF
PUBLIC PLEASE PROCEED YES GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'M VICTORIA ROOM WITH
THE NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL HERE IN SUPPORT.
THIS IS A COMMON SENSE BILL THAT
JUST MAKE SURE THAT OUR
TRANSPORTATION PLANNING IS
LOOKING AT HOW WE CAN BETTER
ACHIEVE OUR AIR QUALITY IN
CLIMATE GOALS AND WE ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU PLEASE PROCEED WITH
YOUR NEXT WITNESS.
GOOD AFTERNOON WILL BEAR WITH
THE AMERICAN LUNG ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA ALSO IN SUPPORT ALL
ONE MY COMMENTS WITH COACH FOR
CLEANER THANK YOU.
MEMBERS THE PUBLIC -- IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL.
SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MATTHEW BAKER
RECLINING CONSERVATION LEAGUE
STRONGLY IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO
HAVE -- CONCERNS WITH THE
AUTHORS BILL OR OR IN OPPOSITION.
SCENE NINE ANY MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE HAVE QUESTIONS OF THE
AUTHOR.
AS IT'S BEEN STATED YOU'VE
COMMONSENSE FILM IS FRIEDMAN DO
YOU HAVE ANY.
CLOSING OUR CLOSING FIGHTING
WHEN I THINK THE CHAIR FOR
HELPING US WITH THE BILL WITHOUT
A RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRIEDMAN I AM PROUD TO SUPPORT
THE BILL -- THE FOR TO YOUR
SUCCESS LISTEN MADAM SECRETARY
IS CULTURAL.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON NATURAL RESOURCES
[inaudible]
FRAZIER [inaudible]
FONG [inaudible]
AGUIAR-CURRY [inaudible]
BERMAN [inaudible]
BIGELOW [inaudible]
JUNE [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
DALY [inaudible]
DAVE HI [inaudible]
FRIEDMAN HI [inaudible]
GIPSON [inaudible]
GRAYSON [inaudible]
MEDINA [inaudible]
NAZARIAN [inaudible]
O'DONNELL.
OKAY WILL LEVY A ROLL OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
SO MADAM SECRETARY LET'S GO
THROUGH THE PROCESS STARTING
WITH THE CONSENT CALENDAR AND
AND DO REAL PRESS MEMBERS PLEASE.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR BERMAN.
BOB CHAIR I DALY [inaudible]
FRIEDMAN [inaudible]
MEDINA [inaudible]
NAZARIAN.
CONSENT CALENDAR HAS TWELVE
VOTES [inaudible]
WE'RE GOOD [inaudible]
SO WELL.
I ONE THE NEXT -- ONE THE
SERGEANTS COLDER ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MISSOURIANS OFFICE SO ANY KIND
OF EDA [inaudible]
OKAY.
THERE IS RIGHT THERE PERFECT.
YOU'RE VERY GOOD.
MISTER NAZARIAN YOU.
HOW PLEASE HAVE YOU EVER?
RESPOND TO OUR SECRETARY.
ON ITEM ONE AB TWENTY NINE
HOLDEN DO PASSED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
BERMAN.
WHICH HI ALL [inaudible]
BIGELOW [inaudible]
SURE [inaudible]
DALY [inaudible]
FRIEDMAN I MEDINA [inaudible]
NAZARIAN.
THAT MEASURE HAS TEN VOTES.
AB TWO SIXTY NINE BY QUIRK SILVA
THE MEASURE THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS.
BERMAN [inaudible]
CHIU HI [inaudible]
DALY.
FRIEDMAN HI MEDINA [inaudible]
NAZARIAN.
THAT MEASURE HAS TEN VOTES.
THE MEASURE IS TEMPLE SITS OUT.
AB TWO EIGHTY FIVE FRIEDMAN DO
PASTOR NATURAL RESOURCES
[inaudible]
DALY [inaudible]
NAZARIAN.
THE MEASURE HAS ELEVEN VOTES
IT'S OUT [inaudible]
ANY OTHER.
AB THREE NINETY FRAZIER DO
PROSECUTING OUR CORPORATIONS
CHIP [inaudible]
DALY [inaudible]
MEDINA.
THIS AREA.
FIVE THAT HAS THIRTEEN IT'S OUT.
SO THAT.
CONCLUDES THE BUSINESS OF THE
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE FOR OF
THIS HEARING.
CONSENT WAS DOUBLE CHECK.
THANK YOU FOR CATCHING THEM.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR NAZARIAN.
THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS OUT.
STILL GOING TO A LEGISLATIVE
BUSINESS BEFORE THE ASSEMBLY
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE.
IS NOW COMPLETE THIS HEARING IS
ADJOURNED.
EASY PEASY KIDS